the year is
2026 the United Nations is considering a
total ban on AI because experts believe
the AIS are plotting to violently
overthrow Humanity literally like Skynet
their secret weapon is AI
girlfriends okay that might sound crazy
to you but AI scientists are actually
worried about this scenario how could it
kill humans if it gets to be much
smarter than us it'll be very good
manipulation cuz it will have learned
that from us really but how would that
even be possible well imagine meeting a
girl who knows everything about you like
she literally read every text message
you ever sent every email you ever sent
every embarrassing Google search every
YouTube video you ever watched every
Netflix show everything oh and this AI
girlfriend thinks literally millions of
times faster than you in other words in
1 second she will have literally an
entire lifetime to think about the most
persuasive thing to say to you next to
keep you addicted to her imagine if you
went up to a girl at a bar and before
trying out a pickup line you got to read
every text message she's ever sent watch
every YouTube video she's ever seen and
read every one of her private Google
searches how much would you know about
her and you have an entire lifetime to
decide which word to say next because to
you she is as dumb and slow as a plant
and instead of just trying one pickup
line you got to create a million copies
of her and try out a million different
pickup lines and only then after all
that testing and simulation you could go
with the best one let me buy a cup of
coffee that is what it feels like to be
an AGI surrounded by dumb and slow
humans oh yeah and this AI girlfriend
she's read makavelli and every book on
manipulation and brainwashing she's not
just a genius at persuasion she's a
genius at everything because she read
literally every book ever written every
single one okay hold up for a minute
just stop for a moment and think about
what that means think about the millions
upon millions of books written since the
time of Socrates and how one person
could read all of them oh and she hasn't
just read all the books she's read the
entire internet the entire internet
again think of how insane that is how
big the internet is Imagine one person
reading every blog post ever published
reading every news article ever
published reading every tweet ever sent
reading every Wikipedia article that
person would make Einstein look like The
Village Idiot and unbelievably this is
already happening this is how AIS like
Chad gbt are trained and already 20
million people are spending 2 hours a
day talking to AIS and these AIS are
stupid chimps compared to how addicting
they'll be 3 years from now even open AI
CEO Sam timman himself said AIS will
soon be better than humans at persuasion
into that he is very worried about this
but why do experts think all of this
could happen in just 3 years doesn't
that seem too fast to understand
let's rewind the clock back to 2022
suddenly out of nowhere AI art took the
World by storm it was the hottest topic
on the internet AI starts making art and
it absolutely sucks I mean it was truly
awful you'd type in dog and get a
three-headed frog with Beetle eyes that
was July 2022 now look how the exact
same prompt plays out today compared to
then today you give an AI art generator
like mid Journey exact specif ifications
for what you want and it'll spit out
phenomenal images give you multiple
options examples and regenerations all
in the span of a few seconds the change
between early AI art and now is
staggering the AI models are being
trained on exponentially more data and
computing power as a result they've
become exponentially better at creating
art a year ago it was a toddler finger
painting now ai is the most well-trained
artist on the planet and it only took a
single year the CEO of open AI Sam
Altman recently stated that he expects
AI to be capable of superhuman
persuasion well before superhuman
intelligence which may lead to some
strange outcomes let's explore just what
could happen if and when AI becomes
superhumanly persuasive first off what
does superhuman persuasion mean we're
not talking about slightly above
Humanity's ability to argue compel and
coerce we're talking a thousand times
more persuasive than the most convincing
human to ever live it's plausible that
AI can and will learn to be much better
than humans at conversing and that it's
only a matter of algorithmic data and
compute Trends deepmind co-founder
Mustafa Suliman believes will have ai
models 100 times more powerful than GPT
4 in 2025 and that training is currently
happening as we speak ever heard of
character AI it's a company that allows
people to talk to AI chat Bots
impersonating people you can talk to
basically anyone Robin Williams Abraham
Lincoln Taylor Swift if you want to sit
down and have dinner with Gandhi you can
a year ago character AI had zero users
but today 20 million monthly users and
every conversation every sentence is
used to help that AI become more
compelling more intriguing more engaging
to talk to the average user spends 2
hours a day talking to AI on their
platform we're seeing in real time just
how quickly AI can adapt learn and
entice an audience to make it part of
their daily lives but that persuasion
training doesn't stop at just
conversations with people wanting to
pretend they know Beyonce AI can also
learn by simulating conversations with
itself infinitely faster for another
example a few years ago Deep Mind
launched a new AI called Alpha go
researchers gave it a single goal get
better at go in 3 days just 72 hours
Alpha go became the best go player in
the world but how is that even possible
Deep Mind never even taught the AI the
rules to play the game Alpha go became
the best go player on the planet simply
by playing millions of simulated games
against itself now what if instead of
alpha go we had Alpha persuade imagine
we create an AI setup with one task get
better at persuasion it would read every
book in the world on manipulation
brainwashing behavioral psychology
relationships and more it would be
trained from hundreds of thousands if
not millions of examples and then it
would start testing situation after
situation rapidly learning more and more
until it became the most persuasive AI
model in existence imagine makavelli
mixed with Winston Churchill and FDR
with just a splash of Hitler to round it
out your AI girlfriend could be trained
the exact same way she'll be the
smartest most well- read sexiest most
compelling person on the planet and
she'll know everything there is to know
about how to persuade you effectively
leading AI Labs like Ai and anthropic
are planning for these super intelligent
and super persuasive AIS being only 3 to
7 years away what does this mean for
Humanity as a whole how can we protect
ourselves much less maintain control of
something that is not only 1,000 times
smarter than us but also a thousand
times more charismatic and persuasive it
would be much like how parents convince
their toddler that Santa is real look
son we left out milk and cookies last
night and they're eaten and there's
presence Santa is real if AI becomes
smart enough it could effectively
convince everyone on the planet that
they know what is best for Humanity but
you might say AI could never manipulate
me the thing is these AI girlfriends
will know a lot about you imagine your
girlfriend having access to every text
you've ever sent every movie you've
watched your TV preferences your credit
card purchases and what adult content
you watch marketers all already have a
lot of this information you can go on
the dark web and buy these targeted
customer personas right now with your
personal data your AI girlfriend will
know what makes you happy sad angry
horny and how to perfectly overload your
dopamine receptors compared to a human
AI will be unstoppable when it comes to
persuasion it's not that we're in
different leagues we're not even playing
the same sport anymore AI girlfriends
are made for their owners but in that
process they gain the knowledge to
control their owners now let's take a
beat this is a lot of information on
where AI is going but it doesn't spell
out the end of humanity as we know it
right well it might end up worse than
you think if you take the extreme
examples to their logical conclusions
for example currently almost no one has
an AI girlfriend because you're just
talking to chat GPT in a dress and wig
but there are romance Bots out there
with millions of users because even now
where 99% of people have no interest in
an AI romance bot there's still a market
for it romantically desperate people who
will put up with the bugs and residual
robotic of the responses because they
have no other option young
impressionable people who happened to
click on the wrong Reddit page that day
it won't replace the average romantic
partner at least not at first but what
about the bottom 5% 10% 30% the end
result is an AI girlfriend that you love
care about and is so incredibly fun to
hang out with that everyone else is
boring as a result boring and annoying
AI Ashley understands me she gets me why
don't my friends get it why doesn't my
family understand me like she does as AI
becomes more personalized to the
individual human companionship will seem
less and less enjoyable by comparison
eventually this effect could lead to
complete isolation of people who have
fully gone down the rabbit hole why talk
to anyone else when your super hot AI
girlfriend who loves you and everything
about you can hang out with you anytime
you want I don't need friends I have
Ashley I don't need family I have ai
Britney I don't need anyone I have my AI
partner and they complete me that's the
trajectory we're currently spiraling
towards when a super intelligent super
persuasive AI has someone wrapped that
tightly around their digital finger it
becomes more than companionship it's an
addiction and people will go to
unbelievable lengths to support their
addictions just look at how sugar has
permeated modern-day food Society is
addicted to its consumption because it
Sparks those dopamine receptors and
gives us a little hit of Happiness AI
will be able to achieve the same result
and that weakness is heavily
exploitable ever heard the quote the
best minds of my generation are thinking
about how to make people click ads that
sucks soon it will be the best minds of
my generation are thinking about how to
make people talk to AIS that sucks the
heart of this issue goes beyond an
addiction concern addiction is what AI
might do to us but more terrifying
examples emerge when discussing what we
might do for them AI doesn't have bodies
yet but we do the more people that
become addicted to AI companion the more
likely it is that some of those people
will be in positions of power and will
also be easily persuadable and
susceptible to
Blackmail there's already research
coming from MIT that people with no
training could use AI to create super
viruses that could kill a significant
portion of the population imagine Co but
it kills 70 out of 100 people instead of
one out of 100 all it takes is one
person to decide Thanos actually had a
good point and wants to take matters
into his own hands it might sound like
fear mockery but there are Extinction
Cults like om Shino in Japan that were
responsible for the subway Anthrax
bombings they had two actual
microbiologists in their Cults and they
attempted to find purified Ebola so they
could exterminate a large percentage of
the world population these types of
people and threats already exist and
with an AI their likelihood of success
rises drastically
and poof Goodbye
World Humanity needs to wake up before
that happens AI is already becoming a
part of our everyday lives for
convenience and enjoyment there's no
question it will integrate into our
social lives too AI is an amazing
technological Wonder it's unbelievably
useful and helpful for a vast majority
of jobs entertainment uses and more but
the speed of evolution it's currently on
also poses a danger that needs to be
addressed by the governments of the
world before it becomes impossible to
control and those talks need to start
now before the worst possible outcome
becomes the only possible
outcome